you keep staring at me over there what
what's going on do you want to hit me
you want to take a second punch
my name is claus marty i'm an ex-drug
kingpin i ran a multi-million dollar
drug business and i was taken down by
undercover cops which led me to six
years in prison one of these people in
the lineup is a former undercover cop
and i'm gonna sniff them out
i smell a little bacon
it's fresh
let's see
you look a little bit serious you can
get me to stare down man
okay
all right let's take a seat how you
doing sir i'm good good all right all
right where are you from i'm originally
from cincinnati ohio oh never lived in
new york yeah i live in new york now
okay okay like eight years now what you
do for work now technical support right
um you look like you do a little bit of
push-ups i do i work out all right i
gotta stay here all right all right you
was trained by the force
no
how old are you i'm 38. get the out of
here
you know i'm 38.
how old i look i don't know you got some
white hair you ain't dirty yet you got
some wrinkles in those eyes black don't
crack that's one time
well i mean you know we've been through
a lot all right great came out on me
when i was 19. i hear that uh what do
you have for breakfast quaker oatmeal no
a donut in the side no no just a piece
of toast you sure yeah that's how i keep
this physique okay and i put a little
peanut butter in the oatmeal all right
so what do you like to do
of
um
well yeah you know that's my recreation
yeah i smoke my own drink no dwis no i
ain't got no details oh you know smoking
drive okay okay
never got locked up before
uh when i was a young young person i had
a little bit of a mismatch youth i got
in trouble when i was young what
happened walk into a store grab a couple
items
didn't have the money to pay for them so
i tried to like dip out the door okay
they had this dude at the front uh i
guess they call him loss prevention or
whatever me and him gotten a little
tussle and so so what what joe you went
to i went to a jail called louisville
it's in ohio it's a juvenile placement
okay yeah i gotta research that yeah all
right all right we'll see yeah i don't
know you don't smell like bacon to me
all right that's cool
let's see let's see i don't know let's
see who's coming up next all right
you guys are setting me up yeah they're
coming
[Laughter]
let's go
how are you i'm good i'm good you
nervous no why would i be nervous i
don't know you sweating your palms just
a little bit i don't know how do you
know when you're my problems i know
you're rubbing them i don't know cops
don't get nervous you know you guys are
confident oh you're right cops don't get
nervous i'm nervous so
what's your name mark mark sounds like a
cop name oh yeah yeah so what do you do
for work i own a limousine company
called the velvet touch out of great
neck oh nice so you're from great
necklace from the story of queens so
you're living in astoria right now no i
live in the bronx now what's your local
precinct
wait a minute i think it's the
45th precinct yeah so you know the
precinct number yeah because i got
burglarized so i had to call them up oh
okay okay i'm sorry to hear that what
happened when i was in spain with my
girlfriend they called me up and told me
they broke into my apartment damn yeah
always worked in the limousine company
no i mean i used to you know at the body
buildings i was a personal trainer i did
a lot of stuff to avoid working with my
dad but whenever i needed money i'd
always i'd always have to drive
undercover cops are pretty confident i
don't i don't know about you man i don't
know about your confidence level yo
you got very white teeth man
there you go i know you guys got the
best dental work
is it the best
i think so man is the city employee
all right all right i'm gonna put you
back on the line let's see who's next
all right thank you you up man
mr brolic here how old are you i'm 32.
you look a little bit stressed man oh
i'm definitely stressed why
it's just life i'm living it okay 100
what do you do for work
well i drive around
for this pharmacy in brooklyn delivering
medicine and people that can't get out
for themselves you know what else you
like to do after work
mixed martial arts
you know combat sports all the boxing
and kickboxing and stuff like that so
you did a lot of training you worked out
i did police
brazilian jiu jitsu not police academy
okay but uh brazilian jiu jitsu
definitely because i'm on a smaller side
so all right you know guys yeah yeah
yeah
get him off of you or you break his neck
so if i'm i'm going over here you know
how you're gonna take me down
i'm going to get that wrist
oh then it's a kimura that way that's
like a cuff position right there no the
arms are going to be like back here
you know what i'm saying get that
and then throw it maybe i'll have it for
dinner later you have been attacked
a few times what happened i was raised
in uh before stuttering do i die that
kind of stuff happened yeah i know you
smoke
used to okay what
just we
what type of wii
i love the green
john b
you know what was the name well i can't
even remember the name you know in the
streets they always change them what was
the name in the streets when i was
smoking it was just green
you look very suspicious man yeah you
don't know what type of green you
smoking i don't know thank you bro
wow welcome
how's it going i'm good what's your name
sylvie what do you do for work i'm a
blackjack dealer
a blackjack deal you look like a
blackjack dealer where you live at in
the city uh i live down in wissahickon
in uh outside of philadelphia so you
drove all the way to the city yes it's
not that far it's like two hours um
you keep staring at me over there what's
going on
you want to take a sucker punch you want
to hit me yeah okay okay you ever caught
somebody reading cards
no that doesn't really matter as much
even if you count and you win you know
how many cards do they fit in that stack
down there uh it depends on the table
that you're at but typically it's gonna
be a table eight times eight decks
what else do you like to do a lot of it
is like sports based so i'll do like
bouldering or i'll go snowboarding or
doing a softball team no i don't i don't
like hand-eye coordination sports
necessarily drive a car
what type of car hyundai elantra not an
impala no you ever had an impala no i
don't know you mad suspicious really
just quick to answer everything i'm just
spitting out
how many push-ups you can do
as many as you want can i see you want
me to see it yeah
right now let me see
that's a good push-up yeah how many you
only did three push-ups well i don't
want to get all exhausted for the
interview
all right you good okay thank you
how you doing how you doing i love you
it rains man mm-hmm they look beautiful
what do you do for work i'm retired
retired from what uh it's classified
i can tell you but i gotta kill you
okay hit me
which ring do you want
let me see if you mark me up i was a new
york city fireman for 30 years so where
are you from i grew up in levittown nice
so you're like in the mobster gangster
field
that's classified you give me a lot of
secrets here
well i'm retired 13 years so you can
just stay home
hobbies you know i skeet shoot
i used to ride horses i was pretty big
into riding horses i own two horses one
i sold one one's retired he lives
upstate did the extreme cowboy races
2010 was the champion iha champion so
you ever rode a horse in times square
no
no not in times square no in manhattan
no i rode mostly on long island or
upstate or virginia or pennsylvania what
do you have for breakfast today yeah
three marble lights and a coffee sounds
like a retired 80 cops excuse me yeah
you heard me a cop yep
yeah okay okay i look like a cop right
i respect firemen yeah you're sure all
right and i respect a few cops you know
the difference
right you know what the difference is
tell me a fireman will tell you how much
time he's got on a job a cop will tell
you how much time he's got left
a fireman wants a little break on it the
cop wants it for free
you worked in new york beverly
stuyvesant what's up what's the engine
number i was in ladder company 111 the
nut house
the busiest house in the world did you
work through 9 11. yes that's why i have
problems talking oh i'm sorry to hear
that man it's all right yeah i was
assigned there i was there a very long
time okay probably too long i respect
your work man
well you do your job great to meet you
man nice to meet you
undercover cops come in all different
shapes and sizes i've seen some like act
pretty ridiculous where it's like
obvious like
you're not a normal character and you're
trying to like overact you know and i
feel like we got a few actors here today
mike
first of all i think you're lying about
your age
yeah i i hear you're you high right now
no i ain't high right now okay no if i
was hot right now i would probably be
eating something okay i don't think he's
my man ah you can step off
my guy
you know police department fire
department you guys like work together
right so you can just tell a little bit
of a lie
and it seems like the truth
i think you know your stuff but i don't
think you're my undercover you can step
off
the blackjack dealer
all right you look very suspicious
me yes you why i think she works for
like buzzfeed or something i don't know
i don't think she's my lady no ma'am
take a walk
so these are the last two gentlemen here
limousine man look like he uh
a little bit nervous i don't know i
don't know if you look nervous but my
gentleman over here you did that
judicial move too quick you almost
cuffed me up get a guy
so i'm about to find out who's the real
cop so i'm going to ask everybody to
come back on stage
all right so the real cop can you take a
step forward and take a bite of the
donut
my man mr nervousness
police officer for 20 years i wasn't an
arc
but i i did
work in warren squad working in the
warren squadron playing clothes i worked
in the detective squad he was the runner
up so you know
i probably would have like walked away
and not so drunk says that's you know do
you mind yeah i had to go ahead man he
said look it he's munching on that he
loves that shoot my blood i to run right
now but i want to do a shameless plug
i'm the founder com body c-o-n-d-o-d-y
what i do is i hire people coming out of
the prison system to teach our fitness
classes i have a gym in the lower east
side and we do virtual training so sign
up peace out